supabase the open source firebase
alternative that's an extraordinary
claim that will require some
extraordinary evidence
because firebase is not an easy thing to
replace it's a whole suite of tools that
include things like authentication a
database you can listen to in real time
file storage serverless functions
and sdks that can easily tie this
infrastructure together on ios
android and the web in today's video
we'll find out if supabase lives up to
its marketing claims but first a quick
disclaimer i've been called to james
brown of firebase
i'm a huge fan of the product and used
it to build fireship io and have helped
a ton of other people build their own
products with firebase so i'm definitely
biased but google has never paid me for
any of this work which means i can say
whatever the hell i want and i'm
intimately familiar with its weaknesses
it's great to see more competition
because that motivates everybody to
build better products which ultimately
benefits us
developers let's start by taking a look
at feature parody which isn't at all a
fair comparison because supabase is
brand new and firebase has been around
for a long time
currently supabase offers a database
user authentication
and file storage with functions coming
soon those are some of the most
important infrastructure pieces in
firebase
but you'll notice a few things missing
like static site hosting
machine learning tools and things like
crashlytics and test lab for mobile apps
and push notifications as well as google
analytics so firebase has way more
features
but supabase has one big advantage and
that's the fact that it only uses open
source technologies for its platform
that means you could run superbase with
docker and host your own firebase
alternative on google cloud platform if
you wanted to that's a big deal because
it means you don't face the vendor
lock-in issue
when you use firebase you're locked in
with google you're signing a contract
with alphabet the corporation
giving them the power to destroy your
business if they decide that's what
should happen
now that's extremely unlikely if you do
what you're told but now let's take a
look at the services supabase offers to
see how they stack up to firebase
starting with user authentication now
first i'll point out that supabase is
not a one-to-one mapping of firebase
it just provides tools that do
approximately the same thing i built a
little demo with supabase and i can tell
you that the developer experience for
user authentication is very similar to
firebase you have a dashboard where you
can view data for all your users and
then an area where you can modify email
templates being sent to those users
they have sign in methods for email
password all the major oauth providers
and also passwordless auth with a magic
email link the only big one that's
missing that you'll find in firebase
is phone authentication now when it
comes to the actual code you'll be able
to get a user logged in with one or two
lines of code just like firebase i
actually really like how it returns an
error as an
object here because in firebase you have
to wrap it in a try catch block to catch
errors that's a small thing but a nice
touch to improve the developer
experience in javascript
now one thing that supabase does that's
very cool that firebase doesn't
is that it automatically creates a
database record for the user
if we go to the database tab you'll
notice a user's table there under the
auth schema
it contains metadata about the user but
most importantly
it's there to facilitate backend
security if we go back to authentication
you'll notice a tab for policies which
we can use to create database rules
using sql
as opposed to firestore where we write
rules in common expression language
which tends to be pretty difficult
code to maintain as your app grows in
complexity now i haven't built a complex
apple superbase but the idea of writing
security rules in sql is pretty
appealing
but we haven't even talked about
databases yet in firebase we have two
different database options but i'll be
focusing on firestore
which is very similar to mongodb and is
a nosql document database
it's really easy to work with scales
automatically and handles relational
data fairly well
however it does have some limitations
and scaling certain types of data
relationships can be extremely
difficult if you need anything
resembling full-text search firestore
actually just recommends you use a
third-party service like algolia
and to be honest that's kind of
disappointing for a company that's built
on top of a search engine
supabase uses postgres as its database a
relational sql
database that's been around forever but
sql databases are expensive hard to use
and difficult to scale
allegedly superbase addresses those
concerns by first handling the scaling
for you automatically
and also by providing a dashboard and
sdk to make working with the database
much easier
now under the hood the platform has
already created a database for us
and if we go to the tables page we can
start adding new tables to it once we
have a table we can then add new columns
to it one by one superbase will
automatically update the schema
and handle the migrations for us in the
background once we have a few columns we
can then start adding data to it by
inserting new rows
that makes it really easy to visualize
and administer your database
but how do we use it in an actual
frontend application like a web app
check this out if we go over to the api
tab
it automatically generates code samples
for us based on the structure of our
database
instead of writing raw sql code you can
use the sdk
to access your data in a dsl that makes
a little more sense
like you can use graphql in the select
method to grab data from a different
table
instead of having to write out a full
sql join overall this feels kind of
similar to hasura which is also an
awesome product that i'll make a video
on
soon the next thing i want to talk about
though is real time if you're building a
real-time app you can do so with one
line of code with very little
configuration and firebase
the client-side sdks are very
sophisticated and do things like
optimistic updates where it updates the
ui before the actual change is committed
to the back end
making everything feel instantaneous for
your end user it also supports offline
mode which is a big deal for pwas and
mobile apps
in supabase you can subscribe to
real-time updates but that's pretty much
it
and to do so you need to go to the
replication tab in the database and
enable it for the tables that you want
to listen to
another issue is that apparently the
security policies will not work with
real-time data
although i think they have plans to
address that in the future the bottom
line is that if you're looking to build
a robust real-time feature you'll have a
lot more work to do in supabase than you
would in firebase
but now let's shift gears to pricing
because firebase is really difficult to
beat on price
so both products have a base free tier
that's really only useful for
experimentation
if you're building something serious on
firebase you'll use the pay-as-you-go
plan
every individual service has a free tier
and you only pay for what you use beyond
the free threshold on supabase you pay
25
a month for up to 8 gigabytes of
database space and 100
000 users compared to firestore which
would cost about a dollar fifty for
eight gigabytes of data
that may sound expensive but in
firestore you also pay for the number of
reads and writes to the database which
tends to make up the bulk of your
monthly cost
but in supabase it looks like you have
unlimited api calls and network traffic
to your database which is an amazing
deal
because normally you have to pay for
cpus to handle the traffic going into
your database
which gets extremely expensive at scale
even for a relatively small database on
google cloud with four cpus
you're looking at almost 300 bucks a
month now if you need more than eight
gigabytes on supabase you can go up to
the pay-as-you-go plan which will cost
an additional 12 cents per month per
gigabyte which is also an incredible
deal
and far below anything offered by any of
the major cloud providers
supabase originally had their
infrastructure on digitalocean
but recently migrated over to aws they
have at least 6 million in funding
currently
but you have to wonder how long they can
sustain this pricing startups don't need
business models that make money
but you would be taking a bigger risk as
a developer because if supabase fails to
raise more money in the future i doubt
their current pricing model would even
cover their aws bill whereas google can
lose as much money on firebase as it
wants
not to mention it owns all the
underlying data centers so it's very
unlikely that google will ever drop the
platform
or change the pricing dramatically
because we all know google definitely
doesn't have a reputation for killing
off products
and that brings us to the question is
supabase legit first of all
i wouldn't really look at this product
and call it a firebase alternative
that's really just a marketing hack to
get people's attention and get videos
like this made but it does have the
potential to get there someday
if you happen to be a firebase product
manager please add an sql database to
the platform i would definitely consider
using supabase for the database alone
it's really the only feature that stands
out to me as offering some potentially
major advantages over firebase
the option to self-host is also a nice
safety net in case the tech overlords
ever turn on you
but in reality the reason people use a
backend as a service is so they don't
have to self-host their own backend one
other issue with superbase right now
is that it only has a javascript sdk
firebase is really popular with mobile
game developers and you can't really
call superbase a firebase alternative
until sdks exist for ios and android
overall i think it's definitely a
promising product but let me know what
you guys think in the comments
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one